president Trump signed a 1.3 trillion
dollar spending bill Friday avoiding
another government shutdown but just
hours earlier the president acknowledged
he was considering vetoing the measure
though the White House helped negotiate
it mr. Trump said he was disappointed in
the spending deal because it doesn't
fully fund his border wall or address
the so-called dreamers young immigrants
who were brought to the country
illegally as children
Errol Barnett is in West Palm Beach
Florida where the president is spending
the weekend Darrel good morning good
morning sources tell CBS News that
Republican House Speaker Paul Ryan was
surprised by president Trump's veto
threat so he called him to convince him
to sign the bill President Trump said he
relented because of increased funding
for the military
president Trump depart at the White
House Friday for his Florida resort
after he threatened to veto but then
eventually signed a spending bill to
avoid a government shutdown a lot of
things that I'm unhappy about in this
bill the president but grudgingly
approved the 1.3 trillion dollar federal
spending measure even though he was not
pleased with the final numbers while
we're very disappointed in the 1.3
trillion nobody more disappointed than
me because the number is so large mr.
Trump said he looked seriously at
vetoing the budget agreement but
ultimately decided to sign it because of
its 60 billion dollar increase in
defense spending we had no choice but to
fund our military because we have to
have by far the strongest military in
the world the spending bill fell short
of the president's 18 billion dollar
request for his border wall he also
noted that the more than 2,200 page bill
was sent to the White House for his
signature hours before the shutdown
deadline I say to Congress I will never
sign another bill like this again I'm
not gonna do it again nobody read it
it's only hours old but the president
ignored the fact that White House aides
and Republican congressional leaders led
the negotiations on the bill the few
lawmakers remaining on Capitol
Hilla before the start of a two-week
recess reacted to the President's veto
threat surprise we're trying to give 18
months of certainty which everybody
needs for the president to threaten to
move us away from certainty to more
chaos and confusion as foolish I don't
think what we did was the best thing we
could done there was the only thing we
could in time so to veto it
wouldn't make a lot of sense to me now
president Trump late last night did
follow through on a different threat
issuing a memo disqualifying those who
are transgender from serving in the
military now this applies to those who
are seeking surgery or medical treatment
and it only makes exceptions in very
limited circumstances the White House
says those with gender identity
disorders pose a considerable risk to
military effectiveness but we should
note this will not take the Mediate
effect because of multiple court
injunctions Reena Errol Barnett
traveling with the president in Florida
thanks Errol